je
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est loïc facile et pour tweet machine
bien sûr moi vous avez reconnu suis baba
mais pour le hit machine il faut qu'il
faut charlie c'est parti un peu d'espoir
pour charlie est allé tout seul
[Applaudissements]
et si on va commencer tout de suite avec
c'est le dernier du classement mais
malheureusement il nous vient d'où je
crois qu'ils nous fiers de leur niveau
de vie
exactement 10 sont rois et aux hôtes
sont avec nous
[Musique]
et
si la saignée
picasso barani ici ball est basé
cheminot
ça fait mal
non
était totale
je vous demande d'applaudir diam's
valérie bouley xi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais c'est pas nicole qui nous avait
donné un cadre non non
ça me rassure non
[Applaudissements]
nous atteignons attention comme à google
dans les locaux de police et l'accueil
d'une auberge et les mains le lendemain
il ya comme un beau don carlos daniel
larusso et là isabelle la route
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec
à
oh
ap
c
quand je crois
ça y est
sûrement
je crois
non
à
oh
je m'appelle aux guitares c'est faux les
chaînes obama
si les tribal king je dis non mais bien
sûr je suis obligé de le dire parce que
la tête qu'ils ont
[Musique]
à
oh
oui
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bravo et catastrophe non non non